[Music]
on this friday night offline and out of
luck
the far-reaching repercussions of
roger's major meltdown everybody's in a
problem and everybody's upset plus
japan's longest-serving prime minister
assassinated the shock and grief around
the world
a devastated community the tornado that
ripped through in alberta town pushing
for arrive can's departure it should be
decommissioned the app's evolution and
why it's sticking around
and the greatest outdoor show on earth
this is really important for the city
the calgary stampede saddles up again
without pandemic protocols
global national with bara nasser
reporting tonight
sophie louie
good evening and thanks for joining us
it has been cash only and absolute chaos
for millions of canadians today a
nationwide rogers outage causing huge
communication headaches for anyone
relying on the network
i woke up this morning i had no internet
no cell service and now i just want to
go and use my debit card it doesn't work
it's a really really scary feeling
having to buy coffee cash instead of
tapping so it's it's been
back to the
future across canada people poured into
their closest coffee shops trying to
reconnect to wi-fi only to find the
entire rogers network was down cutting
internet access cell phone and cable
services atms and electronic
transactions
law courts government offices border
services even 9-1-1 calls all impacted
tonight a representative to the public
safety minister confirms a cyber attack
did not cause this outage as abigail
beeman reports rogers is still trying to
find a workaround
it's a hot mess we're back to the olden
days where everything runs on cash and
you have no contact with anyone you
can't call or text the olden days were
for hunting and gathering friday was
about hunting for wi-fi and cash we've
been driving starbucks to starbucks
trying to get internet connection a
jolting reminder of how reliant we are
on the internet so many people unable to
work and businesses stuck with interac
down too we usually tell people it's
cash only we've had it happen a couple
times people usually just turn around
and go out which is unfortunate but of
course i understand no one's carrying
cash these days we've been up to 74
percent
you know automation puts us back in the
dark ages basically a frightening
problem people across the country who
can't call
to figure 911 an alternative sometimes
easier said than done in an emergency if
you have a landline use a landline if
you need to go to a neighbor to use
their phone use their phone if you're a
friend use their friend's phone as for
what happened rogers isn't saying
offering an apology but painfully little
information an 11 30 a.m tweet promised
to update when they knew things were
coming back online all afternoon no news
it leaves some frustrated by the
dependence on few options in canada with
some bell customers also reporting
problems bell didn't answer our
questions by deadline in canada we've
got problems with concentration of
networks for most businesses
if they had a single point of failure
like that they'd look to have redundancy
two or three times over abigail beeman
global news ottawa
japan is reeling over the assassination
of former prime minister shinzo abe shot
while on the campaign trail in the
western city of nara the killing comes
as a shock in a country with an
incredibly low murder rate and some of
the strictest gun laws in the world as
crystal commansing reports with the
alleged shooter now in custody concern
is turning to security protocols a
warning images in this story are
disturbing
a retired but still powerful figure in
japanese politics
gunned down while campaigning the
assassination of shinzo abe has shocked
the nation gun crime in japan is nearly
unheard of but out near a train station
at a public event abe's alleged killer
managed to fire multiple shots before
being tackled
doctors say he was transferred to
hospital with two gunshot wounds to his
neck he was in cardiac arrest because of
damage to major blood vessels
and his heart
the head of the narra medical university
hospital emergency center said despite
efforts to save the 67 year old he died
just after 5 00 local time friday the
current prime minister tried to maintain
his composure
as he spoke to the nation's grief
we have lost a great politician who has
made many great achievements in various
fields in order to open up the future of
this country
while searching the apartment of the
suspect more homemade weapons were
located police also say explosives were
found a motive has not been shared
was japan's longest serving prime
minister
officers from two agencies were on site
when the shots were fired leading to a
separate investigation about security
protocols
having spent many years in office abbey
was a prominent figure on the world
stage the queen expressed condolences
saying she was deeply saddened to hear
of the sudden and tragic death of abe
shocking is how justin trudeau described
the assassination he was a thoughtful
compassionate
strong leader who
who
understood
the importance of service in india abbey
will be honored saturday with a national
day of mourning
crystal gomansing global news
london a tornado touched down northwest
of calgary yesterday afternoon carving a
path of destruction the twister tore
through the community of bergen alberta
damaging homes at least one was
destroyed the storm also knocked down
power lines and uprooted forests of
trees police say no one was seriously
hurt and everyone in the impact zone has
been accounted for
exactly two weeks after the u.s supreme
court overturned the landmark roe v wade
ruling president joe biden is taking
action
but his options to protect abortion
access are limited and as jackson
proskow explains biden's under fire for
being slow to act
protecting access to reproductive
health care services
putting pen to paper president joe biden
took the first step to stop the rollback
of abortion access in the u.s
we cannot allow an out of control
supreme court
working in conjunction with extremist
elements of the republican party to take
away freedoms biden's executive order is
an attempt to protect women's privacy
and guarantee access to contraceptives
it won't undo the efforts by dozens of
states to ban abortion outright only a
law passed by congress can do that what
we're witnessing is a giant step
backwards in much of our country the
loss of reproductive rights is happening
with remarkable speed half the states
are on track to ban or severely restrict
access to abortion
in mississippi the state's only clinic
closed this week known as the pink house
it was at the center of the supreme
court case that led to roe versus wade
being overturned it's heartbreaking i'm
angry i'm sad and i'm scared in north
dakota local providers are preparing to
pack up and move across the state line
into neighboring minnesota to avoid a
looming abortion ban this is not just
simply you know packing up a
house or an apartment and moving you
know across the city this is learning
new rules and regulations
a full two weeks after the supreme court
ruling biden faces criticism for only
taking action now they missed a
tremendous opportunity in not reacting
immediately not presenting a plan
immediately and this seems awfully late
no matter how good it is on this
critical issue for millions of women
biden's best hope is that democrats can
expand their majority in november's
midterm elections with that they could
pass a law restoring abortion rights you
know this is a time for people to vote
to talk to their elected representatives
especially at the state and local level
between now and then women in america
face a stifling loss of rights and
freedoms and the looming risk of a
federal abortion ban if republicans take
control in the fall
jackson prosko global news washington
convoy organizer tamara leach has been
denied bail after a judge ruled she
breached one of her existing conditions
leach was arrested last week after she
appeared in recent pictures with fellow
protest leader tom marazzo in february
leach was arrested and charged with
several offenses for her role in the
protest that gridlocked ottawa for weeks
she was released with a list of
conditions including no communication
with convoy organizers except through or
in the presence of a lawyer
critics want arrive can to go away
coming up why ottawa is keeping the
controversial app
plus on the decline why economists are
surprised about the newest job numbers
some breaking news to tell you about
billionaire elon musk is looking to end
his 44 billion dollar deal to buy social
media giant twitter in a letter filed to
the u.s securities and exchange
commission musk's lawyer claims twitter
has not complied with its contractual
obligations and the tesla ceo is now
looking to terminate the proposed merger
agreement the deal included a one
billion dollar breakup agreement for
either side
well for many travelers the federal
government's arrive can app is a
nuisance even more so on a day like
today when one of the country's major
cell networks is down and they're
required to provide the same information
on paper
but the app developed early in the
pandemic is still with us today and now
quietly being used for a new
cross-border purpose as ross lord
reports some critics say it's just one
more reason arrive can should be
scrapped
the arrive can app was meant to be a
short-term measure forcing everyone who
entered canada during the pandemic to
follow the government's strict
quarantine rules but a recent software
update has broadened the app's reach
passengers arriving at toronto pearson
and vancouver international airports can
now use arrive can to complete customs
declaration forms before landing in
canada other airports are due to follow
in coming months the government says it
saves time for travelers but some tech
analysts suggest the government is
pulling a fast one the idea that that
public health rationale was used
in a time of fear and crisis to push
this forward you can't you can't just
coast off of that and then switch the
purpose of the app critics already
disliked the app contracts were awarded
without competition to unidentify
companies that were already doing
business with the government we need to
know what decisions were made you know
who's you know so who are the suppliers
what are they being paid
why are they being
chosen even if we're using the same ones
what was the criteria that was used in
order to hire them in the first place
canada border services says it spent
almost 25 million dollars developing and
maintaining the app and another 2.2
million dollars on advertising the
government says roughly 700 000
in-person quarantine inspections have
been completed thanks to the app's data
those inspections represent about 14 of
the total 4.7 million travelers forced
to quarantine after entering canada
the government insists arrive can's new
function is voluntary and that it
engages the privacy commissioner on any
collection of personal information
but with suspicion already surrounding
the app some say the latest development
is too much it should be decommissioned
full stop this should be shut down so
where does the app go from here the
statement from public safety notes no
decision has been made on the long term
future of the app but border services
says arrive can will continue to be
available after travel and public health
measures are no longer needed neither
transport minister omar algabra nor
public safety minister marco mendicino
was available for comment
ross lord global news
statistics canada has released its
latest job numbers and they come as a
surprise to many economists a report
shows 43 000 jobs were lost last month
yet the jobless rate also hit a record
low of 4.9 percent economists say the
loss of jobs is due to fewer people
being self-employed and the decline in
unemployment is because there are fewer
people looking for jobs but concerns are
growing about what comes next the
average hourly wage is up 5.2 percent to
31.24 cents an hour but that's not
keeping up with the current inflation
rate of 7.7 percent the bank of canada
had been expected to raise its key
interest rate three quarters of a point
next week and economists still think
it'll happen because the central bank
wants to lower inflation to two percent
but the canadian center for policy
alternatives warns that strategy has
historically led to recessions
during the periods where inflation has
gone down due to rapidly increasing
interest rates job losses on average
with today's population would be 850 000
jobs lost so there's a substantial cost
to controlling inflation with rising
interest rates
and that is going to fall on workers as
well as potentially causing a recession
economists say a lot depends on consumer
behavior and which combination
of high inflation and rising interest
rates will curb spending
casualties of war ahead what new
analysis reveals about the russian
soldiers killed in ukraine
russia has been tight-lipped about the
number of its soldiers killed in ukraine
its last official casualty update only
admitting to around 1300 deaths while
ukrainian estimates put the russian
death toll at 36 000. now an
investigation reveals the bulk of the
soldiers killed were from poor ethnic
minority groups jeff semple has more
the pankin family has a full house
parents galena and alexi have 13 kids
including nine foster children but at
the family dinner table one seat now
sits empty
the parents say their adopted son daniel
was bright funny and full of energy
after their meal the family gathers to
watch this slideshow of photos from his
life which was produced after his death
daniel was a soldier in the russian army
in april just weeks before his 20th
birthday he was killed fighting in
ukraine
he proposed to his girlfriend before he
left for ukraine his mother says our
family was about to get even bigger but
he never made it home
the pon kin family while rich in love
are from one of russia's poorest regions
when daniel joined the military last
year it offered housing and a salary
several times larger than the national
average
the russian military was one of the only
stable working enterprises says his
father himself a former soldier we
didn't expect the coming conflict over
ukraine he says
the kremlin has remained tight-lipped on
the number of russians killed in ukraine
but an analysis of around 3 600 soldiers
identified so far found the vast
majority are from some of russia's
poorest most ethnically diverse regions
including the mainly muslim northern
caucasus region and siberia by
comparison only a fraction of the
soldiers came from more affluent cities
of moscow and st petersburg
they came here for the money says this
ukrainian civilian who lived under
russian occupation for a month he says
the soldiers broke into homes and stole
tvs bikes even toilets
they were shocked to see our villages
with such nice roads and houses he says
they told me they were afraid if they
quit the military they would be thrown
in jail but many of their russian
occupiers also seem to genuinely believe
the kremlin's claim that they're
liberating ukraine from nazis
the russians said we've come to save you
and i said save us from whom she says
i'm not afraid we have only begun to
suffer because of putin
like many in russia the ponkin family
receives most of their information about
the so-called special military operation
from state tv
and while they could be jailed for
saying otherwise they blame nato and the
united states for provoking russia
our perception of the military operation
hasn't changed much even after daniel's
death he says if anything i have more
anger now who will stop these people
these animals if not our boys after a
few weeks in ukraine daniel told his
parents he was considering quitting but
didn't want to abandon his friends they
were told he was killed by a ukrainian
tank while providing cover fire for his
comrades he was awarded this medal the
russian order of courage
he didn't die in vain she says he died
fighting for peace
a portrait of a russian soldier poor
young men immersed in putin's propaganda
jeff semple global news
together again next we take you inside
the first full capacity calgary stampede
since 2019.
for the first time in two years the
calgary stampede has kicked off its
10-day party with no covet restrictions
and tourists coming back the city is
hoping the big event is just the
beginning of a summer of economic
success but as heather europe's west
explains some pandemic problems remain
[Music]
together again the theme of this year's
calgary stampede an apt one after two
years spectators in their western best
able to line the streets for the annual
kickoff parade
marshall this year with some big star
power kevin costner who often plays a
cowboy on screen saddling up to lead the
way the idea that coded
reminded us sometimes that things can be
taken from us in the wink of an eye
and to understand we can come back out
and celebrate this parade this this
yearly thing that's been happening for
almost 100 years
or over 100 years
but it hasn't happened here since 2019
there was a scale down stampede in 2021
one of the first events to move forward
since covet 19. this is general public
readmission but this year all
restrictions are gone and the tourism
industry is ready to come back big in
some ways the the city really wants this
and this is really important for the
city
our tourism industry has been hit hard
by the pandemic this is a really great
opportunity to get back to work the
stampede says it's not expecting to
break any attendance records this year
focusing instead on getting back into
its usual groove but around the city all
is not quite back to normal yet and some
pandemic caused problems remain catering
companies that are tough on staff
lighting companies sound companies
they're tight on staff so we've actually
had to turn down three events move them
to later in the year
because we just couldn't find the team
still plenty of parties are going ahead
and visitors are ready to take it all in
she's from italy and just visiting us
here in calgary she's my sister it just
looks amazing so far just being with
everyone she wants the cockroaches all
the crazy food i'm really looking
forward to the grandstand show i think
that is sounding really good this year
the hats and boots belt buckles and beer
are back heather urex west global news
calgary
and that's global national for this
friday night i'm sophie louie tonight's
york canada is the town of lake cowagen
in british columbia thanks for watching
tonight
[Music]